vous savez que dans la vie on attend
toujours quelque chose ou quelqu'un lui
il attendait son carrosse voici de
Mireille Henry compé le
caros on allait ensemble à l'école
communale c'était le gamin qui ne jouait
jamais il avait la tête au milieu des
étoiles nous les chefs indiens il nous
ignoraent
il attendait son
carosse il attendait ses
chevaux Tabl noir cheveux en
Bros on l'appelait monsieur
carabos il s'inventait des
baronnes qui visitait son
château et pour promener sa bonne la
bonne
yvone il attendait son
carrosse il
attendait ses
chevaux je l'ai retrouvé dans la rue de
Courcel alors qu'il vendaiit des pierres
àriquet et se baladait couronné
d'étincell comme un Louis
X après un
banquet
il attendait son
carosse il attendait ses
chevaux très fier de lui et de ses
no avec la fille d'un roi d' COS
elle était là sans
couronne pour amuser les
Badeau c'était toujours sa bonne la
bonne
yvone
il attendait son
carosse il attendait ses
chevaux et le temps passait chambardait
la terre on démolissait on
rebâtissait la fortune roulait dans un
bruit de
tonner lui vendait toujours ses pierres
à
[Musique]
briquet il attendait son
carrosse il attendait ses
chevaux c'est merveilleux un rêve de
gosse
quand on y croit de toutes ses
forces et Cendrillon en
personne dormait le soir au
château c'était toujours sa bon la bonne
yvone
il attendait son
carosse il
attendait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]